democratic policy continues to wreck
america's major cities
joe biden has a plan to take those
policies national and
when democrat turns out it's time for
investigations of political opponents
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn so should
you visit expressvpn.com
ben one of the odd things about modern
american politics is how much attention
we pay
to national policy because it makes some
sense i guess because the national
government is so big and because it's so
intrusive and because we spend so
unbelievably much money because of all
of that people tend to focus in on
national policy and that's also true
because of the rise of social media
which means that every issue
is now a borders crushing issue just
because something happened in california
doesn't mean that the next day it's not
going to be tried in
new york or florida and just because
something is happening far away doesn't
mean that
people aren't going to get online and
talk about it well because of all of
this we tend to put all of our focus on
national politics but the reality is
that for most americans
what happens on a day-to-day level is
stuff that is happening in their local
communities and when we examine what has
been happening to america's major cities
over the course of the last 10 years
it is utterly appalling i mean truly
it's one of the reasons why you are
seeing population movements
away from cities and toward more
suburban areas it's one of the reasons
you're seeing population movement away
from places like new york and california
and toward texas and florida people are
voting with their feet at this point
it's the reason
why there is now an actual robust
movement for part of i believe oregon to
secede
and move into idaho it's called the
greater idaho movement it's actually
somewhat successful there's some
counties that are looking to move into
the neighboring state and you could
theoretically see that become
more of a pattern over time and the
reason for this is because america's
major cities are governed according to
ideology
and they are not governed according to
the impact of that ideology
and people in these cities don't seem to
realize that there are
political alternatives they take 10 15
years to realize that perhaps they
should move in another direction
we've had a long history of this in the
united states in the 1960s
new york was a robust forward-looking
place they proceeded to blow out the
spending
focusing on public works projects
focusing on welfare
redoing government undercutting the cops
and by the 1980s
new york was basically a hell hole and
that is when rudy giuliani was elected
in the early 1990s and then restored new
york and now new york
is falling back into the abyss los
angeles saw the same sort
of stuff los angeles moved away from
being the place where
families moved to get a house in
suburbia and it moved toward being a
more
liberally governed city like new york
and then that failed and richard riordan
was elected
in los angeles and since then la has
been moving back toward the model that
suggests liberal governance
and all of the ensuing chaos
has been difficult to watch and you're
seeing this happen in city after city
after city
so today for example the daily mail
reports post-pandemic new york city is
laid bare
as homelessness mental illness and crime
escalate and rattles locals and tourists
alike believe the town has lost its
essence while city cheerleaders insist
the ship
has turned according to the daily mail
in times square the most densely tourist
populated place in the united states
a mentally disturbed man known as mr kim
begs cops to kill him
i want to die you have a gun shoot he
pleads after the officers demure he
picks up a plank of wood and starts
smashing it against the pele soccer shop
on sutton place one of the most affluent
residential areas in the city a lone man
squats on the sidewalk intently reading
a paperback novel next to a shopping
cart that contains his worldly goods he
begs for cash with a sign saying he has
lost everything
trying to survive it adds in greenwich
village a well-dressed man leaves his
office minding his own business when a
menacing character attempts to sucker
punch
him the sixth force who ducks the punch
shrugs and walks away
at harlem's famed 125th street at 2pm on
a sunny may day a middle-aged man sleeps
off whatever he needs to sleep off on a
bus stop bench outside a sneaker store
unaware that his naked backside is
exposed for the world to see these
scenes come from across manhattan as it
struggles to get back on its feet
after the covered pandemic cut off its
lifeblood of tourism sent many of its
wealthiest
residents scurrying to places as diverse
as vermont and florida
and upped the ante on homelessness
mental illness and crime particularly
random assaults and stabbings
governor andrew cuomo declared on
wednesday new yorkers don't feel safe
and they don't feel safe because the
crime rate is up
it's not that they're being neurotic or
overly sensitive they're right we have a
major crime problem in new york city
everything we just talked about with the
economy coming back
you know what the first step is people
have to feel safe again
except for the fact that people aren't
going to feel safe again so long as they
continue to push
bad governance in new york city so long
as they continue to treat criminality
as though it is just another way of life
and so long as they continue to tax the
living hell out of their citizens to pay
for presumably no public services and
simultaneously undercut the cops
and tell the cops they're not allowed to
do their jobs what the black lives
matter riots of last year exposed
is that in america's major cities the
cops have been called off
and because the cops have been called
off criminals are doing what they want
to do
and not only that low-level acts of
criminality become more common
if the james q wilson broke in windows
theory which is basically that if you
allow low-level crimes to predominate
higher level crimes will follow if you
were to reverse that the way to do that
would be to say we are not going to
prosecute high-level crimes and
low-level offenders are going to say
okay well if they're not prosecuting
people
who are you know breaking into shops
openly on fifth avenue
then what do what does it matter if i
jump a turn style
if new york city decides to ignore the
upswing of antisemitic hate crime it's
missed over the past couple of years
then why wouldn't they get more of an
upswing
and the the liberal governance in new
york city has decided that basically
anything you do that is a low-level act
of criminality
is something that should be ignored on
behalf of equity and it's just
it's not just new york city blaming this
on the pandemic ignores the fact that
new york was having serious problems
before the pandemic
new york was basically floating along
the the
same river that the rest of the united
states was in terms of the economy was
really good before the pandemic
but there were underlying problems in
new york city that were already causing
millionaires and billionaires to move
out of new york there are already
problems that were causing people to
look outside of new york the same thing
is true
in california article from the daily
wire today
jeffrey k wood reporting a progressive
coalition of activist groups in los
angeles have targeted
democratic city councilman mitchell
farrell blaming him for the relocation
of about 200 homeless people who are
part of an encampment that had taken
over a public park in his district
so even democrats in la are beginning to
look around and realize the taxpayers
don't exactly like it
when homelessness swamps the city
because homelessness
is not just a matter of people who are
living on the street although again
people who pay taxes have a right to the
public thoroughfare just as well as
people
who are mentally ill or drug addicts
living on the street and allowing
mentally ill or drug addicts or people
who have decided to simply
lawyer to hang around on city streets
is not an excellent way of providing a
feeling of safety and security to
citizens who are paying exorbitant taxes
in order to get exactly that feeling of
security
but in los angeles they've been allowing
homelessness to spiral out of control
for literally years the the aclu
received a court order that prevented
the cops from actually moving homeless
people's stuff
on the street they declared it was
private property of homeless people so
these homeless folks can can be on the
street dirtying a public thoroughfare
that they pay no taxes on
and they they obviously don't have a
right to but you can't move their stuff
because if you move their stuff that's
their stuff
so the public property is their stuff
but also their stuff is their stuff
whereas for you the public property is
not your stuff you don't have any right
to it
free of open needles on the street and
open liquor bottles and people who are
mentally ill and by the way none of this
is compassionate to people who actually
have drug addictions or people who are
mentally ill
one of the great lies that is told by
the left-wing media is that somehow you
are more compassionate if you leave
people to live in their own filth
underneath a freeway overpass
than if you were to actually take
measures to prevent people from doing
that
some of these folks need actual
medication many of them need to dry out
but the basic notion that
it is now the responsibility of
taxpayers to watch their cities degrade
because someone has a right to engage in
activity that deprives them of their own
ability to reason
is beyond it's beyond measure it's crazy
and things are getting worse and worse
in these cities
again driven by the radical left which
is which is now eating democrats in
these cities
and the big problem in a lot of these
cities is that the the alternative to
the democratic governance isn't some
sort of republican being elected the
alternative to democratic governance
is some sort of communist being elected
there's actually the problem in portland
and the mayor of portland who's a
left-wing nut who's allowed riots to go
on in his cities for months on end
that mayor was a bulwark against a
communist was about to win over there
seattle has degraded la has agreed
chicago has degraded
says the daily wire homeless advocates
swarmed o'farrell as michael mitchell
farrell
in l.a on wednesday afternoon as echo
park lake officially reopened after two
months of
undergoing extensive cleaning repair and
renovation the project cost more than a
million bucks
sanitation crews had reportedly removed
syringes guns machetes
and according to a farrell's office more
than 700 pounds of biological waste
so things were going great in the park
don't worry it was making the city
healthier
and freer demonstrators however chanted
shame on mitch
and called for his resignation staffers
tried to shield o'farrell as the
activists shouted and followed him
around the park
before the councilman retreated to his
office a block away this is going to be
our legacy mitch one attendee loudly
predicted
they accused o'farrell of sending lapd
to the 29 acre park in march to sweep
homeless people out of the area
resulting in officers clashing with
protesters after police issued a
dispersal order
o'farrell claimed no one was forcibly
removed by law enforcement the protest
group included activists
representing people's city council la an
alliance convened
by black lives matter of course because
lawlessness is one of the chief goals of
the black lives matter movement
they truly believe that systems of power
in the united states are so
corrupt that lawlessness is required
mitch thought he could show his face in
public and not have to hear from from
people
tweeted people's city council la well
mitchell farrell and his staff got
chased out of the park
this is one this is what it's gonna be
like mitch hashtag mitchwatch hashtag
resign mitch
naturally an organizer with people's
city council allah seeks to unseat
o'farrell when he is up for re-election
in 2022.
activists pointed out signs displaying a
litany of rules governing at the park
those rules are rules saying things like
if you leave your property in the park
it could be removed and impounded
and also you're not allowed to shoot up
in the park but this is bad
but you're not allowed to have cops in
the park according to these activists
okay this is what decades of democratic
governance wreaks and it gets worse and
worse
and one of the reasons that we move from
la is specifically because of these
living conditions
if you're paying extraordinarily high
taxes and receiving zero public services
and you have to worry about your kids
walking out the front door yes that is a
reason to move
the neighborhood we moved from was a
fairly decent suburb
in an orthodox jewish area and as i've
talked about
when you open the front gate on our
property there would be a home
this happened more than once there'd be
a homeless person beating the living
hell out of his bike with a crowbar
because the person
was suffering from some sort of mental
illness or a homeless person face down
in the street with a needle in his arm
yes that happened
or a homeless person sitting directly on
the tree outside your property
and just eating from a can like how am i
supposed to let my kids out the front
gate
and it's gotten worse in the area where
i used to live
how bad did it get well there was a
there was a public private endeavor
called noho west that was fairly close
to where i used to live
noho west cost probably a hundred
million dollars to build it was a giant
giant new mall it was gonna be beautiful
the city of los angeles and the state of
california decided to locate
directly across the street the largest
open-air homeless encampment
in california so they took 100 million
project public private project
that used taxpayer money for the
development presumably and then they
proceeded to wreck it and make it very
difficult for people to go there
because there are literally hundreds of
homeless people who are swarming around
a park right there
now again i have nothing but compassion
for people
who are suffering from mental illness
they require care one of the great
one of the great disappointments of
liberalism is that all the people they
say need care
are me many of the people they say need
care are people who are fully capable of
agency and making good decisions and
then a lot of the people they say don't
need care are exactly the people who
actually require the care
and they refuse to actually put in place
rules that would help those people
instead they consider a compassionate to
let them sleep
under open air in sleeping bags provided
by the city of la
directly across from a public private
development destroying the value of that
enterprise
it's incredible and by the way it's not
just la
it's happening in austin as well we'll
get to that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
want to get healthy and stay healthy you
need to know more about how you make
decisions here's the thing about getting
healthy and staying healthy and
exercising and eating right and diets
don't work because they are short-term
you think okay well if i diet i'll get
to my target weight and then i can
really let it go
wrong you actually have to change how
you think you have to change your
your habits you have to change how your
mind is oriented this is where new
comes in noom will give you the
knowledge tools and confidence to make
strategic choices that turn into
long-term habits
noon doesn't give you rules but instead
teaches you how to think so you can
accomplish your personal health goals
stick with them long term and get
healthy for good based in psychology
nume teaches you why you make the
choices you do
and gives you the tools to replace your
habits with healthier ones noom's
cognitive behavioral approach means
you're not just improving your health
you're gaining the knowledge and habits
you need
to stay healthy my wife and i have been
using noom and it is working great for
us my parents are using nume
as well again it's my wife loves it she
loves getting these sort of tips and the
the information that tells her how to
change her thinking with regard to this
stuff it's worked for her it's worked
for me as well there is a science to
getting healthier it's called noom
sign up for your trial today at noom
n-o-o-m.com
shapiro learn how to get healthy with
noom sign up for that trial today
noomnom.com
shapiro sign up today noom.com
appear over 80 percent of numbers finish
the program over 60 have stuck with
their goals for at least a year they are
changing your habits and changing your
way of life go check them out right now
noom.com
shapiro okay so in austin things have
degraded
according to the daily wire on thursday
austin texas council member mckenzie
kelly appeared on fox and friends to
speak of her fear that the homeless who
are camping on mass around the city hall
area
some of whom are protesting a
proposition that prohibited public
camping pose a genuine threat to public
safety
kelly said i was hoping to find out what
this what their point of view was one of
the great things about living in the
country
we have a diversity of thought we can
all learn from one another but clearly
individuals specifically do not want to
do that
okay so according to kelly she said this
is my main concern not just for my
safety but for the safety of everyone
who works around city hall in and around
downtown some of the residents told this
person
quote you have people who are assaulted
people who are robbed you've had home
invasions
it started with box cutters as weapons
now sadly we joke that we're the machete
capital of texas
the city of austin basically allows them
to do whatever they want
kelly says i've been told by the city
manager the free speech zone will not go
away until august 8th
my problem with that is that this has
happened before during the occupy
movement 10 years ago our city council
ensured there was no oversight camping
on the property my biggest concern here
is for safety she said these people are
armed with machetes they have metal
pipes they have six walkie-talkies
they're wearing bulletproof vests
they've not only harassed me i've had
city staff come into my office over the
last several days thanking me for
speaking out about it because
they are experiencing the same thing
roughly three weeks ago the voters of
austin again a very progressive city in
texas
approved proposition b which prohibits
public camping in an effort to combat
the city's homeless problem
57 of voters approved of the proposition
42 percent
opposed it the democratic mayor of
austin and city council
the city council is 10 democrats and a
single republican
okay but the the travis county
republican chair matt makovic said
tonight is a clear message the city of
boston sent to city hall we're not going
to put up with the insane policies that
make life worse but things have gotten
so bad in austin that there are places
that are seeking to
de-annex from austin and just allow the
state of texas to govern them directly
i mean it's it's truly incredible how
these blue cities are starting to fall
apart
in chicago okay chicago has now
announced their police department just
announced
that they are changing their policy with
regard to foot pursuits
hey what is their new policy with
regards to footprints you want to talk
about allowing criminality to flourish
their policy with regard to foot
pursuits is that foot pursuits will only
be allowed when there is quote probable
cause for an arrest
or it is believed an individual has
committed is committing or is about to
commit
a crime there will be no foot chases
stemming from minor traffic offenses
so if somebody is speeding and they get
out of their car and they run
the police are not allowed to change
them chase them
chicago mayor lori lightfoot said
because foot pursuits are one of the
most dangerous actions police officers
can engage in we can't afford to wait
any longer to put a policy in place that
regulates them
the important parameters outlined in
this policy will not only protect our
officers
the public and potential suspects during
foot pursuits it also serves as a step
forward in our mission to modernize and
reform
our police department the interim plan
includes the following
reminding officers to begin any
interaction with tactics meant to reduce
the possibility of a foot pursuit
defining foot pursuits as appropriate
only when there is probable cause for an
arrest
or it is believed an individual has
committed is committing or is about to
commit a crime
prohibiting foot pursuits stemming from
minor traffic offenses
detailing tactics to avoid a foot
pursuit including
continual communication with the subject
and encouraging officers to position
themselves in such a way to reduce the
opportunity for a foot chase
outlining alternatives to foot pursuits
that should always be considered by
officers including
establishing a surveillance or
containment area and or apprehending an
identified suspect at another time or
place so otherwise
let the guy go let him run away
committed a crime
but you know what is it really worth it
basically what this does is it creates
liability for an officer deciding
to pursue but no liability for letting
the guy go
that's the incentive structure that has
now been created for chicago cops if you
follow the guy you're not going to have
to justify to the police department why
you engaged in a flip pursuit but if you
just let the criminal go
and he goes and he shoots somebody you
can always say well you know what i
really didn't think a foot pursuit was
appropriate
i wasn't sure he was going to go commit
a crime okay
the benefit of the doubt used to be with
the cops
okay and you may say there was too much
benefit of the doubt to the cops
that's an argument but the alternative
it seems
is benefit of the doubt to the criminals
because once you tell cops they can just
not do their jobs
and in fact it is dangerous for them to
do their jobs they're not going to do
their jobs
the new chicago policy prohibits foot
pursuits for criminal offenses
less than a class a misdemeanor unless
the person poses an obvious threat to
the community or any person
and discontinuing foot pursuits if
someone is injured and requires
immediate medical attention
if officers are unaware of their
location and if the need to apprehend
the suspect
the subject is not worth the risk to
responding officers the public or the
subject okay that's that's one that's
just wild okay
so you're supposed to stop a foot
pursuit if the need to apprehend the
subject
is not worth the risk to the officers
or the public or the person you are
pursuing
so in other words if you are chasing
down a person for say smoking
pot in public and let's say that's a
class a misdemeanor in chicago i don't
know what the actual classification is
and the person starts to run away okay
if you believe
that you may have to tackle the person
or if you believe that the person who
knows might be carrying a gun and they
might turn around and you might have to
shoot the person
then you're supposed to discontinue the
foot pursuit
termination of a foot pursuit of
officers engaged in the pursuit believe
they would not be able to control the
suspect
if a confrontation were to occur well i
mean that's literally the suspect has a
gun i can't control the subject
right so i i mean this is madness so the
city of chicago
is now by the way supervisors
are also made liable for this because
now supervisors
are allowed to instruct officers to
discontinue a foot pursuit at any time
and any time there's a foot pursuit
officers have to notify the office of
emergency management and communications
all of this was done in the aftermath of
the fatal police shooting of 13 year old
adam toledo
who pulled who's holding a gun and was
shooting
random cars passing by so this is all
designed to prevent the shooting of adam
toledo
who was in fact engaging in deadly type
criminal behavior shooting guns at
passing cars is a deadly type criminal
behavior
and the city of chicago's solution is
tell the cops to stop engaging in foot
pursuits
how could anything like this can you
imagine why the cities are getting worse
how could they possibly be getting worse
hell
okay well play stupid games win stupid
prizes is the name of the game
over in atlanta which is pursuing
similar policies
according to the new york post an
atlanta mayoral candidate who voted to
sequester 73 million
from the city's police department budget
reportedly had his car stolen
by a group of young thieves this week
and wound up thanking the cops for their
help
city council member antonio brown had
just gotten out of his white mercedes
coupe to speak to fellow community
leader
ben norman in northwest atlanta's dixie
hills community wednesday when he
spotted four or five kids
the youngest only six or seven the kids
were walking around a store and within
seconds they jumped inside his car
one kid was in the driver's seat brown
told the outlet ben attempted to open
the door to get him out of the car
he fought with ben i then engaged and
tried to get him out of the car the
three other kids were trying to figure
out how to get in the car or stay out of
the car he started to hit on the gas and
ben let it go
as he started to speed up and if i knew
i had not let it go i knew i could
probably have killed myself because he
was going so fast i would have started
to tumble he said and i would have heard
him
brown said he filed a report with the
atlanta pd
you know again brown voted to defund the
police
what did brown say he said it appears
the kids acted out of desperation he
said this is a generational poverty
issue
these kids it's 12 30 in the afternoon
why aren't they in school why aren't we
enforcing systems to ensure that if
they're not in school they're in rec
centers
or again you could just tell the cops
never to enforce the law and the
predictable result is they will steal
your car
okay so play stupid games win stupid
prizes
well the good news is that democrats are
attempting to take a lot of this policy
national
so joe biden has already determined that
policing around the nation is going to
now essentially be prosecuted by kristen
clarke who's a wild anti-police activist
we're going to see consent degrees
brought against
most major police departments in the
united states under the doj
you're going to see joe biden continue
to trot out the lie that the police are
systemically racist that the crime
problem in america's major cities
is the results of either the presence of
guns or the result
of systemic american racism already he
had gen saki out there promoting this
nonsense
and then he's going to pursue an
economic policy that
completely disincentivizes work that
makes it more difficult
for businesses to start that inflates
the currency and discourages savings
i mean all of this is bad policy right
and joe biden is pursuing it with
alacrity
and he he wants 1.3 trillion dollars in
debt added to the national debt
every single year for the next 10 years
but he promises that by 2031 when joe
biden will be 88 years old if he is
alive
then the debt will start to come down
and joe biden has been noticing however
that the inflation rate was up wildly
last month
and that the employment statistics are
not coming back as fast as you wanted
them to and so joe biden
yesterday gave a speech in which he
announced well you know you can't reboot
the economy without bumps in the road
well actually you should be able to
reboot this economy without bumps in the
road considering this is the greatest
artificial
artificially induced economic coma in
american history
and until you got there joe things were
starting to look up
and we had booming growth in february
and then by march the growth was already
starting to downgrade and by april it
was stagnating
here is joe biden trying to pretend that
him blowing money into the economy
has actually been a boon rather than a
an albatross around the economy's neck
now as our economy recovers there's
going to be some bumps in the road we
know that of course there will be
you can't reboot a global economy like
flipping on a light switch
there's going to be ups and downs in
jobs and economic reports
there's going to be supply chain issues
price distortions on the way back to a
stable
and steady growth okay except for the
fact
that the entire point of you blowing two
trillion dollars into the economy like
six weeks ago was supposed to be that it
was going to even this thing out
that was supposedly the purpose instead
all you ended up doing was leading to
higher prices because more people
had more money chasing fewer products
and now biden is saying he needs even
more spending because why the hell not
i mean seriously why not joe biden says
his economic plan is working but he
urges additional quote unquote
generational investments all he cares
about
is getting his legacy before he's out
that's all the old man cares about
he says now is the time to build on the
foundation we've laid to make bold
investments in our families and our
communities in our nation
but of course he's not actually his plan
is not working
right and he continues to to blow out
these massive spending programs
meanwhile pushing out regulations and
higher taxes and
and bad social policy and bad policing
policy if you want to
los angeles you're america this is the
way to do it or new york or america this
is the way to do it
and the man guiding us through this is a
man who's locked in a constant
existential
duel with the teleprompter our
continuing series joe biden versus the
teleprompter continued
yesterday when joe biden announced that
alzheimer's patients are going to fill
every hospital bed in america within a
few years which is um
big if true diseases like alzheimer's
diabetes cancers
they're all on the cusp of being able to
be dealt with
you know if we don't do something about
alzheimer's in america
every single solitary hospital bed that
exists in america the nurses can tell
you
every single one will be occupied the
next 15 years an alzheimer's patient
everyone what in the what
okay first of all you're not
hospitalized for having alzheimer's
you're hospitalized with
complications arising from alzheimer's
but beyond that
is is the case being made really that
every single house
like you won't be able to go to the
hospital if you have a broken leg
because there's an alzheimer's patient
in the bed
according to like again this incoherent
old coot
is blowing out the economy and
nationalizing bill de blasio's policy in
new york
and eric garcetti's policy in los
angeles and lori lightfoot's policy in
chicago
meanwhile reporters are just fawning
over him no serious questions for him
they're fawning over the fact that he
eats ice cream
i love the fact that joe biden an old
man eating ice cream
this is considered like wow unbelievable
you've never seen anything like it
here's joe biden eating i i mean the man
can do virtually anything
he can both eat ice cream and also
barely not fall down it's incredible
here is joe biden eating ice cream and
then oh my god just the
the unbelievable virality of the man i
mean virility of man just unbelievable
mr president chocolate chocolate chip
oh yeah oh yeah
look at joe eating chocolate chocolate
chip destroying the economy and making
the yeah
but he likes ice cream guys it's incred
a bunch of children
a bunch of damn children meanwhile
republicans
are doing what they usually do which is
they are trying to counter
democrat spending with spending of their
own which is slightly less spending so
here's the thing about being a
republican guys
if you guys would like to win in the
future you need to stop with this crap
where you just become the democratic
party light when it comes to spending i
understand
that you think that democrats because
they have an advantage with regard to
bribing voters that if you just
half bribe voters that that will work
but let me provide you an alternative
theory
if this is a competition between who can
spend more money to bribe people
democrats will win that competition
so why exactly are you offering a 928
billion dollar plan for quote-unquote
actual infrastructure
a group of republican senators have now
counter-offered the biden
administration's
1.7 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
with a proposal that would spend around
928 billion
instead with much of the money already
coming from expected spending levels
according to the washington post the
bulk of the money would be spent on
roads 500 billion
let me just explain we don't need 500
billion dollars for the damned roads
according to the atlantic 85 of
america's roads and bridges are in fine
shape the vast majority of america's
roads and bridges aren't even under
federal auspices
another 214 billion would be set aside
for public transportation
great water infrastructure and passenger
rail
not a single dime should be spent on
passenger rail okay we don't need
monorail from the simpsons we don't
passenger rail
what is this 1832 passenger rail
about a quarter of the money according
to the post would be new spending the
rest would come from hundreds of
billions in unspent stimulus money or
pre-planned spending
during a thursday press conference
senator shelly moore capito the lead
republican in the infrastructure
negotiation said the 928 billion
cost of the plan would be spent over
eight years republicans say well this is
actual infrastructure you're right it is
actual infrastructure also
you don't need to be in a spending
contest with the democrats because i'll
tell you how this is going to end up
seriously the way that this is going to
end up is with democrats passing a
larger bill
and then suggesting that they are more
generous because this is the way it
always works
i will show you proof joe biden
yesterday he went out and during his
speech at one point he pointed out that
the quote-unquote american rescue plan
for which zero republicans voted
is being touted by many republicans in
their own district
now to be fair to some of those
republicans some of those republicans
added provisions to their bills
that to that bill that brought home the
bacon for their districts knowing the
bill would pass and voted against the
bill because they didn't like the bill
in its entirety so they're sort of
bragging about the fact that they got a
provision that helped their district
into the bill
but here is the reality joe biden saying
you guys voted against this giant aid
package and now you're bragging about
the the quote unquote aid package
it's kind of a telling political point
shockingly the president isn't entirely
wrong here
here he goes even my republican friends
in congress
not a single one of them voted for the
rescue plan
i'm not going to embarrass anyone but i
have
here a list
of how back in their districts they're
bragging about
the rescue plan they touted the
the restaurant revitalization fund
they touted the fact that we're in a
situation where the
dealing with touted grants to community
health care centers
touted i mean
some people have no shame
but but the truth is that he's not
completely wrong when it comes to the
fact that republicans can't have it both
ways
you can't be the party of spending and
then be like
okay well the other guys spend more but
also like i'm glad the spending is
that's not how any of this works here's
what demo
here's what republicans ought to be
doing make the democrats own the
spending make them own the spending
see right now the economy would be set
to boom we're not for the intervention
of the biden administration
now would be an excellent time for
republicans to stay to say listen you
want to pass all the spending it's on
you
really go for it enjoy it's all you and
put all the onus and the pressure
on joe manchin and kirsten cinema to
vote along with this stuff
put all the pressure on mark kelly in
arizona to vote along with this stuff
force a choice for the voters do you
want to spend this much money or do you
not want to spend this much money but
don't
give democrats the ability to come back
and say well you know republicans oppose
the spending but they really didn't
oppose the spending very much
this is why the death of the tea party
movement was such a disaster for
republicans
and we ended up in this sort of populist
miasma where we don't even have the
argument anymore that spending is bad
the entire tea party was formulated
around the notion that blowing out
government spending was a bad idea
and then republicans were like yeah but
what if we out what if we just spent
more money
it was idiotic at the time it remains
idiotic
okay honestly and democrats are ready to
fall right into this binary trap they
are
democrats are out there saying that
democrats should stop negotiating and
ram it through you know what they're
right do it
own it make the democrat tonight let
elizabeth warren own
all the spending she wants to do she
wants to pursue modern monetary theory
and blow out the inflation
make all the quote-unquote moderate
democrats in the senate go along with
that or
choose to side against their own party
put them put their feet to the fire
elizabeth warren more power to her here
she was
on msnbc yesterday i don't
see this just as congress can't
compromise
i see this as right now the democrats
are trying to get things passed that
make sense
like a january sixth investigation
or some sensible gun safety protections
things that are wildly popular all
across
this nation and the republican response
has simply been
no they've just crossed their arms and
said no
we're just not going to do that it's
hard to compromise with someone who's
just
saying no it's not like there's some
place you meet in the middle on that
okay fine do it seriously do it bernie
is saying the same thing
let them be just what they want to be
right bernie sanders
put out a piece at cnn and he says what
happens if democrats go forward in a
different direction
what happens if they spend week after
week month after month negotiating with
republicans who have little intention of
addressing the serious crises facing the
working families of this country
what happens if after the passage of the
vitally important american rescue plan
the momentum stops and we accomplish
little or nothing the american people
want action not never-ending
negotiations and
obstructionism and they will not come
out and vote for a party that does not
deliver
okay force him to the choice man do it
so here's the thing the democrats know
that their record here is not going to
bode well for them and so they've
decided to turn their attention
elsewhere
because they can't make this about their
record they really cannot not in the
cities not nationally
we'll get to what they're turning to
instead in just one second first let's
talk about the fact
that you should be shopping for auto
parts online you shouldn't go to an auto
parts store
you don't want to do it you don't want
to stand in line you get to the front
ask a bunch of questions it takes you
30 minutes to hash out what part you
need and then they're like oh yeah we
don't have that in the back we're gonna
have to order it also we're just gonna
up charge you
or you could just go to rockauto.com and
do it yourself rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts their family business
serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog is
unique and remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you again go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in that how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you and with
the weather warming up and the summer
coming that's a great time to get that
car in order rockotter.com can help you
make it happen
go to rockauto.com right now and check
them out right you appear on there how
did you hear about us box
when you check out with your brand new
parts for your car
alrighty coming up we'll get to more
with regard to
democratic misdirection first i have a
very important announcement we are
looking for a producer
to join the daily wire this could be
your big shot that's right this is a
senior level position
at our nashville hq you can apply on our
website through dailywire.com
careers so if you have at least five
years of experience in broadcast
production
head on over to the website apply
dailywire.com
careers also it is that glorious time of
the week when i give a shout out to a
daily wire member today
it's clark davis on twitter who
understands the importance of proper
home school curriculum
in the pic clark and his family are in
their home classroom while proudly
holding copies
of my book multiple examples of the
world's greatest beverage vessel and
using the crowd or mug as the ashtray
was always meant to be
the caption reads that davis home school
has been tuning into the daily wear for
two years our older kids have been
reading your last book but our
six-year-old couldn't get into it
however he's read knowledge's book a
dozen times
scott dana clark ben kenzie bradley and
ariel hashtag leftist tears tumblr
fantastic take note future homeschool
parents this right here that's how it's
done
thanks for the pick thanks for being
daily we're a member also
now is a great time to become a daily
ware member why well if there's any time
to enter to win a free trip to the daily
wear studio to meet candace owns and see
her live
show it is like today now this is your
final warning it is your last
chance if you sign up now as a daily
wire member with code vip
you'll get 20 off your new membership
and be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two
to daily wire studios to see candace
live the deal ends on memorial day
do not wait another minute not only will
you be hanging out with candace you'll
be getting an inside look at her studio
and front row seats to watch her take
down leftist live in action
on her talk show candace you're not
going to get another chance to don't
sleep on it enter
now win two vip tickets to a candice vip
pass right now
at dailywire.com subscribe using code
vip for 20
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
alrighty so meanwhile the biden
administration not wanting to focus in
on their policies
it's time for investigations gang we
need investigations this is why the left
is so focused in on the january 6th
commission idea okay now the reality is
there are some questions that could be
asked about january 6th
seriously like there was a a three-hour
gap apparently
between when the riots began in the
capital
and when the police actually arrived on
scene when the when
law enforcement arrived on scene to stop
all that what happened during that
three-hour intervening period
we could find out why exactly nancy
pelosi had not wanted
more law enforcement on premises at the
time
we could find out exactly how law
enforcement officers behaved in the
middle of this because there's tape that
has emerged of some law enforcement
officers
basically kind of moving away were they
just trying to funnel people into a
different space like what was going on
exactly okay but what the democrats want
from this
from this january 6 commission pretty
obviously is to make the 2022 election a
referendum on trump
and to suggest that all republicans are
complicit in january 6th which is why
they're going to make it about
the rhetoric what led up to january 6.
what was the ideology in people's minds
which again is a crackdown on ideology
and a crackdown on how people think and
how people speak
not really an investigation into the
systematic law enforcement failures that
allowed people to breach the capital
building
okay we didn't have the 911 commission
was really not about the ideological
roots of al-qaeda
it wasn't we knew what the ideological
roots of al qaeda were the 9 11
commission report
was really about the systematic law
enforcement failures what exactly
happened but democrats don't want to
restrict this
to what exactly happened on that day
they want it to be broader and they want
this thing to take beyond the boundaries
of the year they would like this to
bleed into next year
so they can continue talking about
january 6th and then they can say listen
no matter how badly we've governed the
country the people on the other side
those guys are the real threats of the
country they're the ones who are truly
scary this is why joe biden continues to
fulminate
over january 6th it was six months ago
order was restored inside of a few hours
and the vote went forward
the only person who was killed was one
of the rioters ashley babbitt
that's the only person who was murdered
on scene well murder is strong who was
killed on scene
okay the the cops who died on who died
there's no evidence at this point that
they were killed on scene by the rioters
so is that i mean george will suggested
it was comparable to 911
in terms of how americans should think
about it that of course is incredibly
silly
911 was a full-scale attack on the
united states that ended with both world
trade center towers collapsing
a full-scale plane attack on the
pentagon and another plane
being brought down in a field in
shanksville shanksville pennsylvania and
over three thousand americans dead
this was a bunch of droogs running into
a building and then running out of a
building
many of them getting arrested an order
being restored and all of the processes
going on within like an hour so
not the same but we're going to continue
to focus in on january 6 because
if your policies are failing this is
what you do here is joe biden pushing
the january 6 stuff
i can't imagine anyone voting against
the establishment commission
on the greatest assault since the civil
war on the council
but at any rate i came for ice cream
that's right
the greatest assault since the civil war
since the civil war
like you know how many bombings there
were like every day in the 70s
many of them targeting government
buildings you remember last summer when
two billion dollars in property damage
was done by rioters in major cities
around the country
remember that and what what in the world
okay but we know what in the world and
that is political misdirection
the media are fully invested in this
they are
pointing out which republicans are are
supporting the
nine uh the the one six commission those
would be susan collins lisa murkowski
and mitt romney
have also have all said that they are
supporting that is not a shock of course
then there are about nine republicans
who are still considering
that that would include shelly moore
capitol west virginia bill cassidy of
louisiana mike krappo of idaho
jerry moran of kansas rob portman of
ohio ben sasse of
nebraska john thunder south dakota pat
toomey of pennsylvania and roger wicker
of mississippi joe manchin said today he
thinks there may be five or six
republicans who are in favor but a lot
of republicans are not
when asked if he would break the
filibuster if he would vote to nuke the
filibuster in order to get the one six
commission
manchester was like nah i don't think
that's appropriate
would you be willing to break the
filibuster in order to get this passed
the claim
destroy our government i'm not going to
destroy our government no i think that
they
will come together you have to have
faith there's 10 good people
okay and if there aren't 10 good people
in his view if there are enough
republicans then guess what democrats
will launch their partisan commission
anyway
i mean we all know where this commission
is going don't we the whole point of
this is to keep trump
front and center in the american public
imagination
that that is the entire goal here
because we kind of know what we were
going to know and the only stuff that we
don't know
could have been found out by democrats
during an impeachment inquiry which they
decided not to do
in favor of rushing that thing forward
so they could get an impeachment on the
books so nancy pelosi could claim she'd
impeach trump twice or something
as though she got extra points meanwhile
if you don't like that investigation
they've got other ones on the way
according to the new york times federal
prosecutors in brooklyn
have been investigating whether several
ukrainian officials helped orchestrate a
wide-ranging plan
to meddle in the 2020 presidential
election including using rudy giuliani
to spread their misleading claims about
president biden and tilt the election in
donald
trump's favor according to people with
knowledge of the manor more
investigations into ukraine and russia
sounds great the criminal investigation
which began during the final months of
the trump administration and has not
been previously reported underscores the
federal government's increasingly
aggressive approach
toward rooting out foreign interference
in american electoral politics
much of that effort is focused on
russian intelligence which has suspected
ties to at least one of the ukrainians
now
under investigation now you'll recall
that the entire russia
collusion investigation came to nothing
after years
of the media pumping it get ready for
more of this now the suggestion is going
to be that russians operating inside
ukraine
were trying to skew the 2020 election
now you'll recall that there was no
investigation
into ukrainian efforts to skew the 2016
election why because the ukrainians
were on hillary clinton's side this is
from politico january 2017.
donald trump wasn't the only
presidential candidate whose campaign
was boosted by officials of a former
soviet bloc country
ukrainian officials tried to help
hillary clinton and undermine trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for
office
they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aid in
corruption
and suggested they were investigating
the matter only to back away after the
election
and they helped clinton's allies
research damaging information on trump
and his advisors
a political investigation found a
ukrainian american operative who was
consulting for the dnc
met with top officials in the ukrainian
embassy in washington in an effort to
expose ties between trump
top campaign paul manafort in russia
according to people with direct
knowledge of the situation was there a
federal investigation into that no
no so more investigation by the way
there are certain investigations they
are not happy about the democrats
some of those investigations include
like the only important investigation
internationally right now which is
whether kovid was
leaked from a wuhan lab that is
important because we need to know
when the chinese government knew about
kovid if they knew about this thing in
november
and then they waited until late january
to announce that it was humans of human
transmission
not only are they responsible for the
leak they're responsible for the three
million dead people across
the world and the nearly six hundred
thousand dead people in the united
states
and yet there's a certain lack of
curiosity when it comes to our media
and the lab leak theory and the chinese
cover-up a complete lack
of curiosity for example dr ezekiel
emanuel
who is an advisor to to joe biden and a
former health policy advisor in the
obama administration
he was on msnbc saying who cares how it
happened why does it matter the answer
is if you want to stop this from
happening in the future
maybe we should know how it happened
also you might want to punish the
government that hit it for months here
with zika manual being an idiot
we need all the data and we need
transparency and we do need the chinese
to participate because
you know the real issue is not how did
this happen the real issue is
how do we protect ourselves from the
next pandemic
uh and how do we have a kind of early
warning
system uh for whether it's naturally
occurring
or a laboratory leak we still need to
protect ourselves so we don't have
three four five ten million people die
unnecessarily well one of the ways that
you protect yourself is by finding out
whether
chinese labs were engaged in the sort of
sloppiness that allows
a deadly virus to leak from the lab and
then maybe you don't fund them
right then maybe you don't trust the
chinese when they tell you there's no
human to human transmission
taiwan didn't trust the chinese they had
very few deaths south korea didn't trust
the chinese
hong kong didn't trust the chinese
government
the the amazing lack of curiosity on the
part of these
public health experts it's shocking
except for the fact that
anything that doesn't abide by their
agenda is just ignored
by them which is why we spent a year
with social media shutting down
any sort of speculation about the lab
league theory
now and now only is facebook deciding oh
yeah i guess you can talk about that
publicly
now pretty incredible stuff alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
first you can't forget end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com this evening at
7 pm eastern 6 p.m central
and tune in also monday's memorial day
so the show is not going to be live but
there will be a tribute show for
memorial day you're going to want to
give it a listen
in the meantime have a great weekend i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowski
editing is by adam's science audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin